okay so I'm very excited because we're
off to interviewed rich roll who is an
ultra man athlete will be competing in
the ultraman championships and why at
the end of November he's a vegan stud
triathlete a new triathlete and I'm a
triathlete in training so I'm very
excited to talk to him about his running
his biking swimming the journey for me
started when I turned 40 and I was quite
overweight and out of shape and turning
40 you know for a lot of people makes
them sort of think about you know their
life and what they've done so far and I
realized that I really needed to make a
change and try to go entirely vegan
entirely plant-based no animal products
and see how that feels and what happened
was very quickly after I did that within
seven to ten days I experienced
tremendous surge in my overall energy
levels so I started working out again
and and then slowly over the next couple
months realized that I that I wanted to
go home
the gold-rich chose was the ultraman
championship an exclusive three-day 320
mile individual ultra endurance
he'll be swimming 6.2 miles he'll be
riding 261 miles and he'll finish all of
that off with a 52 mile run it's an
invitation-only race so and I had to
call up the race director and appeal to
her and try to convince her to let me
into the race because they limited to
just 35 people she said what have you
done and I said the nothing but I'll be
ready and I don't know why she believed
me but I kind of kept at her for a while
and she allowed me you know she was
gracious enough to let me enter the race
so that began the journey of trying to
prepare for this you know three-day kind
of ultra endurance event really animal
products and animal proteins in
particular not only are not necessary
they can be counterproductive and and
disease provoking as well so I think the
biggest sort of benefit in terms of
being an athlete and preparing for an
endurance event in particular is your
ability to recover in between workouts
animal products and animal proteins tend
to be acid forming foods and so your pH
becomes more acidic which is which
really impedes your but your body's
ability to repair itself and recover
when I decided to do triathlon I was
thrilled to see an article written by
rich on the front page of cnn.com
I knew I had a lot to learn from this
amazing vegan endurance athlete
as a result of the CNN piece I got
unbelievable number of emails from
people who really want you know a
solution now it's just a fad diet but
you know a real lasting permanent way to
change their habits that's going to have
long-term health benefits you know
prevent heart disease turn off cancer
cells to prevent diabetes like all these
sort there's just you know a litany of
amazing you know health benefits and
reasons why it's a good idea so you know
I would like to say to everybody out
there that not only is it an option for
you I would you know I think that it's
advisable and that you know maybe you
should try it for 30 days and see what
you think one of the biggest things that
that that I'm learning more and more
about is factory farming and the the
environmental implications of eating a
plant-based diet you know the way that
our food is prepared the way it's made
and the way that animals are treated in
that and it's been you know shocking and
eye-opening you know the biggest impact
I think that you can have on the
environment is avoiding animal products
in your diet what is your favorite place
to Train right here
yeah we live in the Santa Monica
Mountains in Malibu Canyon and it's
paradise for trail running and cycling
and swimming you know state park terrain
with you know hundreds and hundreds of
miles of beautiful untouched trails for
running and it's you know it's really
meditative and beautiful so can you tell
us a little bit about 2010 what are some
of the races you're considering well I'm
gonna have to I'm not sure yet I mean
I'd like to I still haven't done an
Ironman yet I've done the double
higher-ed but I'd like to try an Ironman
and then I want to do some of the the
ultra trail running races whether it's
western states or there's a race called
marathon to sob which is in southern
Morocco it's a six-day race across the
Sahara Desert I'll figure it out soon
but probably not until after this race
but the adventure continues I am rich
roll for PETA go vegan plant strong
you
[Music]